just a second I'm sorry apparently
someone in the audience has a question
yeah yeah I have a question how you
doing how you doing that's your question
okay I got a follow-up question hello my
name is karma and annunzio can I be you
travel correspondent my travel
correspondent no no actually I do all
the travel segments myself
that's too bad I'm the best for example
I just did a travelogue in the city
called Las Vegas you want to see it now
we really yeah one person but now come
on the news reel here guess where I am
Las Vegas I guess we should have maybe
pulled out on that Jeff here we are in
Las Vegas which is Spanish for hey
everybody have a great time all right
but you Louis possibly have a good time
you can relax here and you're totally
awesome Skyloft sweet so freakin huge
watch how long it takes me to walk the
other side
I'm still walking
look at me I'm in another zip code
shoulda brought breadcrumbs luxury is
metabolic boss
I prefer rolap I'm dying here Carbone an
area this is easily the best vodka sauce
I've ever had even better than my mom's
God rest his soul
I'm sorry ma don't worry about it
yeah hey are you in the mood for a show
you should come down to MGM Grand check
out these amazing dances the
Jabbawockeez we're kind of like hip-hop
baby dance we're a jewel night club
where I got laser stares jaws easily the
hottest nightclub in Las Vegas
I got bottle service i service glass
service napkin service it's off the hook
Liz I think that confetti service like I
just won the Super Bowl
we got to check out the Bellagio
fountains easily the best fathoms in the
whole world there are naturally
occurring phenomena nobody knows how
they got here the hotel around and in
conclusion that's the endless
entertainment on Las Vegas you should
seriously come here and just do all the
things that I talked about back to you
Oprah
okra yeah
I'm sorry I got kind of excited and was
that whole thing at paid integration for
MGM Resorts yeah yeah I said that no you
didn't oh well what are you going to do
see you next time on c'mon D'Annunzio
travels to nearby cities that he can get
to easily
[Music]
he's literally my favorite part is he
had a stroke at the end that's the
takeover of a comeback Judd Apatow is
with a snicker out
you
you